I know Blake Shelton is leaving The
Voice yeah Gwen was probably the first
to know her hubby was leaving the
singing competition after season 23.
[Music]
you have to figure out who this new
Blake's gonna be right
um but I'm just so proud of him I mean
he's brought so much joy he's so
talented and I just I know people just
wait around to to laugh and watch him on
TV so I feel sorry for everybody he's
gonna be gone and um yeah I just I just
I'm so proud of him but Blake is not
saying goodbye to our screens just yet
hey I'm Blake Shelton I'm Carson Daly
and I'm Nikki Bella and this is I would
think I was a guinea pig I was the first
episode me and Cheryl Crow so
um it's a fun show with my wife I think
she just felt a little bit sorry for me
for sure we got some beer goggles for
you all this is like when you agreed to
marry Blake Shelton Drive completely
different from the boys I mean it's
literally just people hanging out doing
games in a bar so right up Blake Sally
ET catches up with Gwen at the 2022
Matrix Awards the ceremony honors women
and media
honestly just um I feel a little
overwhelmed like I it was just one of
those things that I I didn't even really
know existed so they were like they want
you to come to New York for this thing
and I'm like me like okay okay okay so
I'm here and um I feel totally honored I
I obviously went and did the research
after I found out it's been going on for
so long and it's just um it's exciting
it's one of those things where
really like how how did I fast forward
from Anaheim girl to New York girl right
now
[Music]
I'm so happy he's here I can't you know
he works so much that having him do this
extra is like always like a lot but we
had a date night last night we went out
to dinner it was so fun and it's just so
fun to be back in New York it's just
been so long I am humble and excited to
speak about my wonderful wife and duet
partner today as she is honored for
putting women at the Forefront and
championing women consistently
throughout her prolific career
I am proud to present this Matrix award
to a woman with three Grammys four VMAs
a Las Vegas residency two fashion lines
a beauty line and a strong sense of self
who's helped pave the way for women and
rock my favorite person Gwen Stefani
everybody
[Applause]
[Music]